the nights are long this time of year in
the Arctic and the days are very short
for thousands of years large Miguel it
sees people the Sami have lived here
according to the seasons but the seasons
are getting harder to predict normally
we would have snow by this time it's a
late winter this year and that's
something we've seen more of
since the last ice age ended the Sami
and their ancestors have depended on
reindeer for food but reindeer herding
is about more than just that it's about
identity is this maybe when you feel the
most Sami yeah you're really a Sami you
feel that you're really really deep in
the Sami culture when you're working
with in the craft if you take people
away from reindeer herding they would
lose an important part of their culture
a few times a year the reindeer are
chased into Corral's herders from around
the area come to collect any reindeer
with their markings and bring them back
closer to home mating season is over now
so the males are about to lose their
antlers anyway
Lars Miguel and his buddy Yohan are
helping saw this stags antlers off so he
doesn't hurt other reindeer in the
trailer the animals live and grays and
the wilds of northern Scandinavia but if
the winters keep getting warmer due to
climate change their risk of starving
yes you can see the candy but he cannot
get it because it's a it's ice between
the food and the candy he's talking
about are these lichens there's a saying
in these parts the reindeer used to feed
the Sami now the Sami will have to feed
the reindeer so far it hasn't actually
come to that feeding the reindeer
doesn't make sense for the animals or
for business the thing with the Ranger
is that this is their natural food and
feeding them hay year-round is not
normal for them and reindeer in a Corral
and it's not it's not made for that they
make a living for us in nature but to do
that they have to be able to get to this
stuff basically that's that's key for
their survival and for the survival of
the Sami the modern world is already
chipping away at their identity reindeer
herding has long been an integral part
of
identity if that's lost people here will
have to find a new way of life